bonjour les amis d'aujourd'hui avec
maxence garni tôt et m'a tenté de se
poser un truc sérieux qui vient de se
passer
j'ai trouvé mon jean entendez ou pas les
amis aujourd'hui tout ça pour dire qu'on
est sur ta mère a aussi passé tôt
regarde bien parce que normalement quand
on est là et permettre une nouvelle et
bonne nouvelle oui ok je dis donc on est
sur ta mère en slip lâcher quoi que ce
soit ni de salaire en slip que j'aurai
un jeu neuf sous blister sous les
nouvelles halles et ouvre le jeu vous
rappelle les règles c'est extrêmement ça
on a chacun une paire de lunettes avec
deux quarts sur les lunettes lune
d'écart et une personne est l'une des
cartes et une activité il faut deviner
le nom de la personne est l'adjectif qui
correspond en posant des questions par
exemple puis j'ai un homme ou une femme
est ce qu'on est obligé de gens vivent à
personne mais ce qu'on peut pas
s'identifier à quelqu'un d'humain est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à vivre une
expérience hors du commun et à fermer
google pour qu'on puisse jouer au jeu
aujourd'hui je comprends
si moment où ils ouvrent le paquet c'est
un peu long c'est vrai c'est ce que ça
aurait pu être sympa je suis moi quand
je vais dans tes vidéos by the way we
voilà c'est parti
[Musique]
m
coc
[Musique]
m
ok les amis à tour de rôle vous allez
pouvoir poser des questions pendant une
durée limitée pour trouver tout d'abord
le personnage vous avez trouvé
personnage vous passez à l'adjectif
alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui on
va commencer par mc fly attention top je
suis réellement n'y a jamais été aussi
serré un dessin animé
oui je suis en trois dimensions ou
dessinés à la main en trois dimensions
mais alors ici que c'est fini oui eh mec
je crois que j'ai jamais vue avec fois
ci il pourrait soulever la question pour
eux maxence c est vrai qu est-ce que
c'est johnny hallyday non parce que
c'est vincent lagaf un os que c'est pa
ti deux objectifs que fictif
effectiveness est ce que est ce que je
suis un homme
non parce que chantôme remplacé fini les
sorties de salut c'est vrai nom attendu
secondes tu me dis j'essaie de monter la
fin de friends
ok c'est parti je suis un personnage
fictif
non je suis un personnage réel qui fait
la télévision oui présentateur de jt non
oui d'accord c'est pas le jt c'est la
météo n'ont mené ses idées vous êtes
beaucoup trop stressé vous pouvez vous
détendre non ma douche ou non je peux
jouer peut-être bien c'est parti ok je
suis un homme
oui oui je fais de la télé non juste une
réelle oui si les jurés lcd jeunes qui
me regarde oui malheureusement oui c'est
un ainsi qu'annie fait un peu télé
malheureusement ceriu tube heures mais
il continue d'ailleurs de bonnes montées
un truc ok ok j'ai fait un peu de télé
mais non initiés mcfly top sa version 3d
masculin wii reste on m'a que non non
mais genre depuis dix ans le premier oui
oui on l'a tous vu sortir de taule
photo rigolote il a des pouvoirs et
avoir nullement hockey basket après ses
passages à l'animal non ok c'est pas
toujours il est d'une évasion je voulais
tellement transport a été arrêté donc je
suis pas un objet pas une famille un
animal si nadine chez un animal enfanter
oui non non c'est bien mais ça va pas
ouais pause
[Musique]
voilà c'est tellement raison mais c'est
faux regardez la première ligne sont des
animaux excusez moi la question un truc
mais lui n'en dites moi et moi j'arbitre
je vous dis ça je sais quoi tu te dis le
nom d'un personnage dessin animé très
connu au moment où le temps vient à
normal tu es prêt c'est parti arnold non
les razmoket mais pourquoi t'as que des
clubs de 2009 aujourd'hui le particulier
dans son jeu c'est de dire les blagues
bon accueil ça me fait mal d'être le
palmashow excellent d'abord été pris ou
pas on y va donc je suis donc un
présentateur hommes de la télé française
sa démission n'est pas un jeu non non ni
un divertissement si c'est arthur non
non mais c'est dans ce genre là oh oui
est-ce que je suis marron la danse est
elle tout le monde pense que non ok
d'accord mais je suis gagner des sous
aux gens non non aux jeux c'est fini
c'est fini
hanouna toi c'est pas guy lux taille un
sac va niger s'est passé est ce que je
le connais bah oui probablement oui oui
et youtube heures non on peut le dire sa
tête face aux young boys c'est le niveau
zéro du journalisme voilà et il est
youtuber niveau zéro aussi
ça balance pas mal à paris et hurni fut
donc grande hystérie marc théry marre de
la qualité quand vous avez le nez qui
coule du tout et apprenez du taquin pour
les panaris j'ai appris ça c'est david
simon hésitent à arrêter de faire des
placements
j'avais un mal de tête j'ai pris du
dafalgan dafalgan mais arrête de la
scène et ça va bien non zeego ce que je
suis dans l'univers marc bayard ya un
peu maintenant univers marrant n'empêche
que les petits plats picard quand même
quand on est en galère ça saoule
africains arrêtez de faire des
placements en fait ça fait genre 30
minutes personne n'a trouvé le perso
j'ai trouvé ce nom aux cellules tu vois
c'est la psychologie enfin mcfly avec
une manipulation d'enfants
sa tournée est ce que je suis le héros
de ma fiction oui série a peuvent les
ponts secondes ratant son tour
cailleteau tu es prêt est-ce que je suis
sûre il a nourri non non tu es cyril
hanouna mais sous un autre nom assez bas
oui est ce que le contexte dans le carré
droit est un lieu non non ok c'est une
activité oui oui baba fait la vaisselle
baba fait deux overdoses n'ont pas fait
du corps ni baila n'ont pas construit un
meuble ikea à bas âge est un trio
brabham et des petites lunettes pour
jouer au jeu avec ses potes ne va pas ça
donne à la chaîne de mike cunningham a
effectué le dab autant dire qu'il aurait
il faudrait à vue il a rarement vu au
lavage pour garder le focus on dirait un
moine tibétain qui n'a rien d'un moine
et qui n'est pas du tout tibétains moi
j'ai rien on peut se montrer très vite
et c'était une piste de ski chez toi
sale que si tu ne garde pas moi je vais
en péter dans son studio
c'est parti on y construit là il a une
technique personnelle
ouais mais c'est ouais mais moi non je
veux pas on distingue c'est très
important l'aspect personnel moi je le
connais pas personnellement de l'aspect
artistique et c'est le vide
artistiquement je vais vous dire je les
rencontrais personnellement c'est un mec
hyper cool c'est juste que ce qui fait
ça va pas
tiens à dire un truc aussi que meilleure
vidéo que les mecs c'est ça qui te
montage séquestration la même chanson
vous faites un peu avant et un petit but
avant tu vois là je me chauffe jet de la
quatrième partie je pense qu'il serait
vraiment bien on tue la passion puisque
hitler m n'est pas trop mon style tu as
quitté mec arrête et acquitté c'est fini
bon on peut juste 2 on apprend sont
conscientes je suis sorti deux ans on m
appelle c'était avant eric affronte une
sortie deux ans avec l'avant-bras gauche
de squeeze et il a quitté il en avait
marre il lui écrit sur facebook je te
quitte à vider la tête après tout mais
bon je crois que j'ai pu faire le deuil
du couple quand on écrit sur ce n'est
pas tout noir va se voir offrir un bijou
comme si rien ne s'était pas demandé
pourquoi il avait appelé ses enfants
avant et ben jassem un mec réfléchit pas
de quoi tu la vénère et rentre chez lui
il va sûrement chile sur facebook
l'invasion de la manne pour les enfants
oui je suis le héros d'un pour adultes
aussi pixar walt disney lui mort ok ok
macsoft est prêt ok attention top est-ce
que c'est bob l'épongé health qui récite
de changer son assurance vie non mais ya
le mot change dans l'histoire est riche
en sons venant s'ajouter pas échanges
est-ce qu'elles échangent des cartes non
mais ils échangent un truc il ya une
notion des chances
il y a une notion d'échangé son sperme
et c'est pas loin ses habitants mais son
salaire a dit henri chômage
c'est une activité mais tu vas dans un
lieu lundi se passe quand même le bon
c'est vrai que pour le pauvre garçon
comme après il vient me voir après la
vidéo il mon cas lucas les gens il vient
de coin car ô toi tu vois il parle comme
ça tu vois la galerie des halles gamme
et mais tu veux tu en es tu veux qu'on
leur laisse peut-être le temps de se
rabibocher les uns vient d'atteindre
rester là et nous on vous laisse le
temps mais voilà tous bons tous vont
s'en ressentir
alors les gars écoutez c'est pas moi
mais le temps du mois comme il est il
est de mauvaise foi en plus je sais pas
si je te remets ta came back sens laisse
moi avec max à chaque fois après la
vidéo oui à chaque fois on prend la tête
je sais jamais pourquoi dites-vous une
qualité que vous pensez de l'autre allez
je peux pas il est chiant alors à l'est
après la chute des tours guère mieux en
arrimant gueule vous n'êtes pas d'accord
tu n'as tu le regardes tu regardes la
bête utilise une qualité aller jusqu'à
bon bouquin c'est à toi maxence denis un
compliment sur luca luca tu sens bon
c'est sympa déjà prévus voilà bien le
cas toi maxence oui mais voilà
tu as de beaux chevaux bon bah voilà ok
maintenant un petit rapprochement
physique voilà on sera pas se regarder
on se regarde mon regard d' arrêter ou
gêne allez on se regarde voilà
et maintenant tu espères plus ça tu me
promet un an
qu'est ce que tu fais là ils te tuent
c'était gentil avec lui on ne ramène ton
pied mais question alors voilà barrès
mais ça n'a pas devant les gens que j'ai
dit vas-y voilà allez on peut y
retourner
allez les garçons on y va ottawa comme
on associer deux plats sont un peu
perdus sakari tôt ok donc baba et
c'était quelque chose de physique
ouais un mouvement physique et il fait
un truc pour faire croire qu'il ait
jamais fait pas le tab n'ont pas fait un
dab j'ai déjà parlé du jeu de top 20
mois est-ce qu'il a pas plus de cent
mille abonnés oui est-ce qu'il ya plus
d'un million d'abonnés
oui mais pas loin il reste un grand il
fait des interviews des chants issus un
truc cool et sympa j'ai trouvé le délire
à journalistes sont admis sur la foule
puisse dire eh oui jamais proche d'un
animal affaires à l'instar d'un jour
négliger reggae alger une agglo masse au
total
je voudrais un maximum de commentaires
sur la vidéo pour bob l'eponge c'est un
animal je veux hashtag bob l'eponge est
un animal tim mc fly en allant
représente pas moi alors pour vous bob
l'eponge est une éponge de vaisselle
mais qui vit dans la mer une erreur je
ne vis pas dans la merde ont admis dans
la salle à manger
la question pour vous pour essayer de
lui mais je n'ai rien j'ai eu marc au
secours au secours valeur pour essayer
de faire avancer le débat est ce que
vous faites partie des gens qui
humidifie leur brosse à dents avant de
mettre le dentiste dans le débat ah oui
c est ce qu après avoir fait caca vous
essuyez debout ou assis mais est ce que
vous faites quelqu'un dans le noir est
complètement nul est ce que vous avez
déjà pensé après avoir fait caca vous
essuyez par-devant est ce que dans la
douche vous puissiez tout au plus et
meurent en ce sens tout chaud c'est quoi
il ya quelqu'un qui a vécu dans cette
pièce a personne qui tient la caméra
moi j'ai envie je vienne ici et qui nous
dit s'ils pensent que bob l'eponge est
une éponge de vaisselle ils ont une
éponge de mer ont bien du mal et de
contrôle de la terre que maxence et avec
moi ils ont ils pensé faire la vaisselle
ou pas ah oui oui oui on va faire venir
cette personne on accueille
et voilà m mais voilà mes tableaux de
karité voilà symbole tu connais bob
l'eponge collé au plafond
attention attention tu répond de manière
simple et efficace selon toi est ce que
bob l'eponge est une éponge de la mer
donc l'animal ou une éponge qui permet
de nettoyer les restes de ton steaks
hachés dante à poil ou autre chose mais
pour lever c'est les mecs ça va ça va
touche pas tu choix d'une journée ça les
mecs c'est pas grave enfin c'est un
débat de pointage n'en touche bête tu
viens me dérange pas mais tu m'as dit
oui nous tourne à 10 touchés fait
incroyable jeudi deux fois touche pas en
vrai faut que j'aille cpie je me retiens
de mon fils et je vous signale qu'on est
seul sur la chaîne de l'ue-15 san lucas
on fait ce qu'on veut alors qu'un abonné
vous a lâché 2 mai car étant celle de
maxence qui est l'étoile montante un
bijou on essaie de donner le maximum
pour innover pour vous plaire maman je
t'aime tiff matin le thème dix ans qu'on
est ensemble je t'aime merci merci
encore vous m
ok ok vas dans l'isr dans un club
échangiste
voilà c'est donc tu es bob l'eponge qui
va dans un club échangiste bon allez
allez hop là attendez moi j'ai gagné je
veux pas enlever à oui mais en fait ça
fait 45 minutes vous faites semblant
détenu lui on peut se moquer le capter
près ouais bon je suis jeremstar eh oui
ok je fais une activité qui appartient
au groupe je suis retourné oui oui il
faut le nom de la tournée ok c'est parti
m c'est en rapport avec internet ça se
fait sur internet non jour sur youtube
oui ils réclament un podcast sex and
gaming sexy caméra cachée non pas une
dégustation ces enveloppes
est ce qu'on va pas nous même écrire le
ta mère et le ensuite nos personnels
activité totalement oui vous êtes prêts
oui ok carlitos j'écris ce qui rassure t
lunettes mais si on avait dit qu'un toit
et moi personne ne voulait que maxence
et crimes parce qu'il est perché il va
écrire dalida fait du chemin fait
ensemble maxence
raté
[Musique]
d
les amis c'est fini nous avons tous des
lunettes
nous sommes prêts je propose que j'ouvre
le bal ok tout l'humour c'est parti je
suis réel oui oui je suis un homme
oui oui je suis acteur c'est pas ton
activité concept je suis chanteur oui
oui mais oublie ça a vraiment je suis
acteur mais le chanteur est ce que je
suis réellement j'ai fait du théâtre et
ça se passe sur scène aussi
ok c'est parti ok suis-je la télé non
sur internet oui jeune homme ou une
femme un enfant
oui mais où ouais je suis néo je fais un
truc où je suis dans un truc où il se
passe des choses assez d eau ou tu fais
quoi pour il va vite sans casser partie
parce que je suis victime n'ont pas su
chan hom
oui je suis vieux oui parce que je manie
les mots oui à la reine est ce que je
fais quelque chose oui oui oui et c'est
une activité quotidienne on n'en voit
que c'est un extrait what the fuck nom
fictif dans un film we trilogie doudou
du logis jolo ok je suis roquettes mais
regarde la veille au matin j'arrive
juste en train de parler des gares et la
galaxie longueur qui fait l'attrait
skipper propos de ce film à dia sur ok
ayem groot guère s'étonner qu'il y ait
des groupes fait une activité physique
c'est physique au sens du terme que ça
engage le physique c'est un truc en
rapport avec un déplacement avant de
l'évincer oui très juste a donc route
mais des craintes non justement non
c'est fini ça c'est moi qui fait pour
toi plus riches heures de pacotille
petite fraîcheur de pacotille a grandi
en banlieue enfin côté je n'ai pas coupé
les pattes beaucoup perdre
et parle pas loupé gbagbo au dans la
gorge ça marche le faire ok sur fabrique
des choses non non je suis architecte
sur cette activité est connu il fait
quoi il fait du stand up de l'humour
gad elmaleh non [ __ ] on y voit secret
proche de dubosc et c'est mon activité
oui oui je suis néo je suis dans un lieu
oui c'est un monument
non mais c'est aussi connu pour ça mais
c'est pas un lieu de visite touristique
on y est allés nous dans notre vie n'en
et on n'a pas le droit d'y aller si on a
le droit à un ensemble avec maxence
activité physique n'en avions non gluten
c'est pas kamoulox à l'activité
cérébrale oui c'est aussi sa tournée un
jeu société non non je fais des avions
en papier un truc que tu aimes bien vert
de souvent toi qui chantes ça fait dur
oui oui d'activités particulières c'est
un triste highway tué à la va vite c'est
parti donc c'est un serveur en avant et
que pee wee un truc que tu portes c'est
utile
ok ils portent des shoes en pointe non
il fait quelque chose mais c'est là
s'est il fait c'est quoi ces routes
adversaire c'est fini c'est fini c'est
fini
cette fois c'est une activité qu'on fait
dans un jeu spécifique c'est un truc
moche et soir oui c'est un double nature
est atypique
non trop basse a fait un café ménages
non non bingo
regardez en ce moment de ma vie là je
vais bien le savourer gros toutefois
celle là le propriétaire de cette chaîne
possède le seul on le laisse finir en
somme ça vous dit ouais bon balle et
salue le mec merci mozart qui tient tout
cas merci de nous avoir invités on se
retrouve bientôt pour une vidéo sur
notre chaîne la shem de max merci le cas
merci pour tout pas sûr
à bientôt mais s'ils gardent c'est hyper
cool en tout cas de ba voila de nous
avons invité
abonnez-vous à la chaîne mce ricard
d'eto'o se retrouvent tous les dimanches
matin à 10 heures pour des vidéos hyper
sympa et marrant tu es morte
[Musique]
québec les mecs des magnats grecque
ouais
est ce que je suis lucas
non
j'suis m'arrivait dessus les mecs merci
de m'avoir jour pendant cette vidéo très
longue
on a passé un bon moment j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait nuit blanche
alors le milan c'est que je pu
littéralement la merde à ce jeu
n'hésitez pas à passer dans la chaîne de
mcfly et carlito merci maxence d'être
venu n'hésitez pas et voit la chaîne
maxence était jeune vous à voir et on se
dit à très vite pour une prochaine vidéo
si on m'a dit vous faisait ses lacets